voici une tresse typographie capital de
1890 restaurer fonctionnel muriel dutil
vise toujours pour les particuliers et
avec les écoles il y en a dans les
musées ne fonctionne pas
moi je fonctionne et c'est le but muriel
a toujours le regard espiègle typographe
dès 14 ans puis enseignant ce passionné
collectionne depuis des décennies un
patrimoine rare mais à 81 ans il
aimerait passer la main l'idéal ça
serait que
en l'honneur des applis marcela de la
touraine
que ceux qui musée pédagogique
culturel un patrimoine ancien reste
reste à tours où ou en touraine les
collections présentées en partie sont
intimement liée à l'histoire tourangelle
aux grands noms de l'imprimerie plantain
mam bros mais aussi balzac lui-même
imprimeur mais plusieurs métiers dans
l'imprimerie et surtout un typographie
et donc ça s'est conservée par par
muriel casse et de connaissances et ça
c'est important et c'est pour ça qu'on
voudrait que ce soit conservée dans la
ville qu'on puisse conserver cette ce
savoir faire et c'est historique
la semaine dernière on allait chercher
sa part hissé voix grave et qui
illustrait une livre sur jeanne d'arc
donc voilà ça c'est le bois et puis on a
l'impression qui est assez exceptionnel
d'ailleurs puisque le bois est passé en
portait de conservation le musée qui
ressemble davantage à un cabinet des
curiosités réclame désormais plus d
espace dans 70 mètre carré exigu seule
la moitié des collections est présenté
mais elle attire toujours autant jusqu'à
3000 visiteurs chaque année